the historic indictment against former
president Donald Trump the twice
impeached once commander-in-chief is set
to be arrested for the second time in a
little more than two months on Tuesday
following yet another indictment but
it's the first time ever in U.S history
that a former president has faced
federal charges prosecutors unsealed the
bombshell 49-page indictment against
Trump Friday the White House hopeful
faces 37 felony counts for his alleged
mishandling of classified documents
those were recovered at his Florida home
including willful retention of National
Defense information
conspiracy obstruction and giving false
statements to investigators Christina
raffini has more from Washington
Christina good morning
good morning Dana will this indictment
really focuses on Trump's refusal to
produce these records because although
sensitive documents were also found in
the personal offices of former vice
president Pence and President Biden the
difference is they willingly gave them
back
boxes and boxes and boxes in a bathroom
in a ballroom stashed under a water pipe
we have one set of laws in this country
and they apply to everyone the contents
of those boxes according to the
Department of Justice included sensitive
and classified documents it says Trump
knowingly and willfully retained are
laws that protect National Defense
information are critical to the Safety
and Security of the United States
and they must be enforced
violations of those laws put our country
at risk
special counsel Jack Smith kept his
remark short letting the 49-page Federal
indictment speak for itself
the document quotes an alleged
conversation between Trump and his
lawyer with Trump saying wouldn't it be
better if we just told them we don't
have anything here Trump later
suggesting his attorney hide or
destroyed documents demanded by a
subpoena the indictment also cites
multiple incidents where prosecutors say
Trump showed off sensitive materials
including sharing a highly sensitive
plan of attack against Iran with
visitors at his New Jersey Golf Club
telling them on an audio recording of
that meeting the contents of which were
confirmed by CBS News the document is
quote highly confidential and secret
adding as president I could have
Declassified it now I can't you know but
this is still secret
prosecutors are trying to use Trump's
own words against him including this
pledge from the campaign in my
Administration I'm going to enforce all
laws concerning the protection of
classified information
no one will be above the law the
unprecedented Federal indictment is the
culmination of a 14-month investigation
during a search of the president's
Mar-A-Lago home last August the doj says
it recovered more than 100 records
including classified documents and some
marked top secret
Trump who broke the news of his own
indictment online thank you I'm an
innocent man I did nothing wrong was
seen golfing in New Jersey Friday and is
calling it The Boxes hoax they come
after me because now we're leading in
the polls Again by a lot against Biden
and against the Republicans by a lot
traveling in North Carolina Friday
President Biden said he had not spoken
to the attorney general and had about
the case but Speaker of the House Kevin
McCarthy did this is going to disrupt
this nation because it goes to the core
of equal justice for all which is not
being seen today as did Trump's 2024
Republican Rivals I think there needs to
be one standard of Justice in this
country let's enforce it on everybody
and make sure we all know the rules is
this the type of conduct that we want
from someone who wants to be president
of the United States
now I will say most of Trump's Rivals
with the exception of a few were
reluctant to directly criticize him
that's because they're trying to win
over his voters without alienating them
Trump's expected to appear to Miami
court next week and he has public
appearances later today in Georgia and
North Carolina where I'm sure this will
come up Dana
all right Christina thank you